j'accueille maintenant un autre marin un
autre grand marin voici michel rocard
non
vous serez le coach et le regard bonsoir
bonsoir ans que oui vous êtes à côté
vous n'êtes pas entre eux wade avait
commencé par une connerie je suis un
tout petit vin mais non arrêtez vous
serez vous n'êtes pas grand chêne la
vrai nom mauvais mari adore ça vous êtes
l'inventeur de la deuxième gauche c'est
quoi la deuxième gauche oh non je suis
pour l'inventaire de la deuxième gauche
l'inventaire de l'adhésine bout c'est un
nommé jean jaurès ouais je séculaire ce
truc
la deuxième est liée à deux tempéraments
principaux il y en a un qui est jacobin
centralisateur uniformisateur commandant
très politique ne croyons pas beaucoup
syndicats ni aux accords et pensant que
tout se décide par la loi par le
règlement par la discipline et c'est
jules guesde
paul fort tout le monde a oublié mais
c'était le chef entre les deux guerres
c'est le chef de mes ongles ou guy
mollet françois mitterrand à deux sets
rapides dans cette gauche ainsi fabriqué
dans notre pays bizarre c'est toujours
les minoritaires se comprend il pouvoir
qui ont été le mieux entendu de
l'opinion aux différentes époques et
c'est jean jaurès léon blum pierre
mendès france
aujourd'hui peut-être jacques delors et
moi voilà c'est ça voilà les roues des
66 vous imaginez la décentralisation
avec un ouvrage s'appelle décoloniser la
province un beau titre quand même très
bien superbook et on l'a fait alors
merci qui l'ont dit et je le redis
souvent c'est laurent l'on connaît un
joli jeu en regard des enjeux d'ordre
c'est bien j'adore rythme à trouver le
sommeil je n'ose pas il ya toujours été
très rocardien heureux l'add on va donc
je reviens donc à vous êtes l'homme du
règlement du conflit en nouvelle
calédonie l'homme du rmi de la csg et
aujourd'hui vous militez pour le
désarmement nucléaire notamment
bon alors ça c'est tout ce qui est
positif dans ce cas négatifs
séverin négatif ce n'est pas de votre
faute vous a été le souffre douleur de
françois mitterrand rien de négatif
non non pas ça vous empêchez opposant
l'as public quand même j'en ai assez
fait pour m'arrêter avant bon alors vous
êtes vous savez elle me faire un plaisir
formidable ouais ça fait 20 ans que le
truc effet j'ai 70 ans les peuples un
viol c'est la première fois que
j'entends à la pas seulement à la télé
dans la vie en général quelqu'un place
et la csg dans les trucs positifs à vous
venez de le faire prodigieux talent et
défoncé sa joue ici
parce que c'est en effet un bordereau
soit 15 % des français y ont gagné
l'argent mais ils ne savent pas ouais
mais votre destin attendait quand même
vers la présidence ne dit pas c'est pas
grave j'en ai fait assez
on peut dire ça bon je suis planté uno
dizaines de la route encore à aider
quand même ouais il est probablement
plus important de laisser des idées qui
font souche que de signer des trucs soi
même a tracé une contrepétrie c'est bien
alors michel rocard ou publie un livre
un livre d'entretiens avec ghislaine
troubles chez flammarion donc je
m'attends d'ailleurs jamais président là
il a bien vu michel ladi lafé donc si
vous voulez j'imaginais balladur en
train de faire ça pour coupat pourquoi
pas bien donc laissons lui sa liberté
ses chances mais tout à fait que je suis
démocrate
bah oui j'ai bougé un syndicat des mecs
qui ont failli être présent dans le
public je pense donc à nouveau élevé
entre vous alors collection mémoire
vivante donc entretien comme je le dis
avec judith waintraub c'est votre
parcours d'homme politique
vous êtes né en 1930 activement comme
vous le disais ça vous fait quand même
au moins 70 ans vous avez dix ans qu'on
y voit un bon poids vous avez dix ans
quand la france et est envahie et vous
fait vos études sous l'occupation
votre père grand résistant quitte la
france en 43 et pendant un an et demi
vous n'avez pas d'autres nouvelles de
lui que les messages codés qu'il vous
envoie par l'intermédiaire de radio
londres
alors votre père c'est un grand
physicien non dangereux c'est un des
pères de la bombe nucléaire et voilà
alors c'est terrible votre père a été un
des inventeurs la bombe nucléaire
française et vous vous êtes contre la
prolifération des armes atomiques
bah oui il ya des contradictions dans
toutes les familles moi ma mère je lève
mon mais je laisse pas donc
la jcct magie alors votre première prise
de conscience politique c'est en 45 g de
scouts pendant l'occupation c'est
interdit d'être scrutin pendant
l'occupation
oui on s'appelait patronage mouvement
s'était pas scout est alors à la
libération des éclaireurs unionistes et
vous allez accueillir les déportés qui
reviennent des camps et ça effectivement
ça vous marque profondément parce que
vous avez 15 ans vous voyez j'apporte
qui - sur la marques n importe qui est
la deuxième prise de conscience et quand
vous découvrez un jour qu'hitler a été
élu au suffrage universel et vous vous
dites la politique ça peut être
dangereux vaut mieux s'en occuper 10
coup les chevaux quand vous résumer tout
lé nom je vous lis la fête la politique
mais vous l'avez faite bien alors
j'avance moi je fais le pitch au lycée
vous découvrez que votre talent aux
mathématiques sont pas à la hauteur de
la tradition familiale et on peut dire
nulles
ah ouais je n'avais jamais osé mon père
aimant maintenant passer sans rien dire
un joli mouvement je répondrai dans
votre famille sont tous normalien aux
polytechniciens dans tout ce
polytechnicien de père en fils mon père
ayant trahi mais vers le haut normal
c'est encore plus assez mieux enfin
c'est ce qu'ils croyaient vous
connaissez le vôtre clemenceau en 1919
ouais merci
vas-y voulait empêcher l'allemagne de se
relever créer une école politique oui
d'ailleurs j'ai quand même d'une crue
opéra alors un jour donc vous voyez bien
que vous n'allez pas y arriver quoi et
profitant d'un voyage de votre père aux
usa de mer à rome vous vous inscrivez à
sciences po
vous me taire agit très malin et vous
coupe les vivres t'imagines la famille
quand même me dis je vais faire sciences
politiques à polytechnique
alors vous devenez tourneur fraiseur
dans un labo de l'école normale
supérieure et la gagne un peu de poids
mais pourquoi je raconte ça parce que
j'ai c'est votre conscience l'éveil de
votre conscience politique que j'essaye
d'expliquer là vous êtes initié au vécu
de la classe ouvrière par un
contremaître trotskiste ancien des
brigades internationales on espère les
tourneurs voilà un gars qui avec un tube
d'aluminium et un tour avec de manivelle
était capable de vous tailler
demi-sphère trop loin ça va intéresser
magail
ouais ça va lui appellation et la
présence comme ça mais mais en même
temps il me racontait la guerre
d'espagne c'est vrai oui alors c'est
vrai quand on vous soupçonne d'être un
socialiste de droite quand même quand on
voit d'où vous venez c'est pas si c'est
pas si simple que ça là ça va être
compliqué
aulas il ya deux définitions de ce que
c'est d'être de gauche y en a une par le
salaire le pognon le plus de pognon et
c'est pas neutre il ya des tas de gens
qui bouffe mal l'ennui c'est que trois
ans après l'inflation vous l'a rappelé
le plus souvent et l'autre manière c'est
les droits droit d'exister le droit de
se syndiquer je dois parler le droit
d'être entendu devant détroit présenter
le doubs l'équivalence du droit des
femmes par rapport à celui des hommes
le pacs la reconnaissance tout ça sont
des droits et cette définition de l'art
de la gauche est de créer des droits qui
sont irréversibles eux et c'est l'anti
colonialisme maintenant je me suis battu
pour le droit du peuple algérien j'avais
balancé sur l'algérie à un moment
définition d' à gauche au nom de
laquelle je suis entré c'est celle des
droits ouais la bataille pour la dite
faut aussi corriger les inégalités mais
c'est plus fragiles parce que c'est à
remettre sur le chantier tout le temps
voilà comment je suis en train dans le
coup j'ai parlé politique pardon non ça
va c'est est clair c'était clairement
mais on n'est pas contre la politique
mais celle dans les contrées chez eux en
fait c'est une catégorie à l'échec
j'essaye de ne pas pardonner mais de
temps en temps le petit con alors après
la guerre bat vous parler un petit peu
de vos amours mes premières amours alors
c'est les premières amours furent
protestante dans le cadre elle pas
d'accord normalement quand protestante
dans l'est dans le cadre de la paroisse
mais bute agréer mes premières amours
les plus profondes
or il ya les premières amours et les
ports notamment les plus profondes
spacieuse et fait gaffe en disant ça
mais furent cependant anglaise donc on a
compris que dans la paroisse il se
passait pas grand chose c'était quoi
baiser avec la langue et puis après
l'angleterre c'était un peu plus sérieux
c'est ça michel keil pas michel nous
avons britannique sur fabuleuse et
platonique
ah bon ouais les britanniques sur la
télé convenablement elle était fiancée
en plus
mais c'est quand même à ça que je dois
te parler anglais ce qui est dans le
monde contre pour les skates par rapport
à $ ou bien alors votre première femme
était d'ailleurs cheftaine chez les
louveteaux way japon devront pas
s'attendre à l'école et non je rigole
pas du tout la deuxième il avait
rencontré au ps eut ouais vous avez
emménagé avec elle en mai 68 et en 91
vous annonciez avec sincérité rare dans
votre milieu
pas chez les hommes politiques en tous
les cas votre séparation oui s'appelait
michel rocard c'est ça ce qui vous
embête et vous avez tous les deux michel
rocard donc s'appeler michel van trop le
dire comme ça dites-moi deux couples
deux échecs
c'est pourquoi votre mère était trop
possessif c'est ça non peut être bien
j'ai en effet une main très possessif
qui va pas faciliter mes rapports avec
la partie civile de l'humanité qui est
pourtant des plus délicieuses plus puis
j'ai peut-être pas eu de chance et puis
j'ai peut-être penser ce qu'il fallait
peut-être que je suis un mauvais mec il
intervient alors vous entré en politique
à travers les réunions d'étudiants de
socialistes si vous n'êtes pas la carte
d'ailleurs ils vont rencontrer jacques
chirac était socialiste à l'époque
jacques chirac
il aurait pu n'ont jamais réussi à lui
faire signer la demande d'adhésion mais
il venait souvent réunion je réalisais
nous étions de la même promo de sciences
po on était bien copains c'est vrai
qu'il a défendue l'appel de l'ange g
oui justement je vais tout vous dire il
me considérait comme beaucoup trop
réactionnaire pour lui chirac chirac
ce livre vous l'interrogiez vous le
confirmera non mais on veut pas une
seconde de votre parole mais il était
plus à gauche que vous chirac
oui c'est pour ça que c'est fait à temps
avouez quand même c'est génial on
découvre aujourd'hui que mitterrand
était de droite que chirac était de
gauche alors qu'ils sont fait élire sur
un programme contraire s'en dit long sur
la politique en donner 15 secondes là un
mot de mon père et il apprend que je
deviens socialiste catastrophe non
seulement tu vas bharati n'était pas bon
pour les sciences exactes mais en plus
que faire de la politique à gauche là où
ils sont ou seront site était comme tout
le monde c'est mon père qui parle tu
sais trotskiste
ouais je voudrais tout casser
ça ne ferait que deux ou trois ans parce
que tu comprendrais si tu deviendrais
normal mais si tu commences sens social
démocrate tu va le rester
oui et ça c'est pire phrase m'a été dit
que j'avais 19 ans et je suis toujours
là alors vous avez été vaccinées en fait
contre le contre le communisme parce que
quand vous avez lu le livre de crafting
co c'était en quelle année ce bouquin
après la loi c'est tout 48 qu'est ce
qu'il y avait dedans
la description de l'omnipotence
policière et du contrôle d'un régime sur
les relations personnelles les
déclarations la vie privée les paroles
de tout individu dans une société
totalement insupportable et décrit avec
un tel talent littéraire que vous ne
pouvez pas douter que c'est un
authentique sanaa ça ne peut pas
s'inventer salive qui a été connue à
l'époque par bosch france vient ça me
fait un immense chêne et comment vous
expliquez que des gens sensés après
l'avoir lui soient restés au pc sur les
staliniens
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont besoin
d'une église et dans toute église des
combats à la fois ou moins n'importe
quoi le communisme était une église et
les croyants sont restés croyants du
moins ils se sont tirés petit à petit
petit à petit ça a pris du temps quand
même parce que avril il y en a qui l'ont
été jusqu'à 89 ouais je sais bien ça
fait beaucoup plus tard ça fait quarante
ans plus tard mais le livre nous nous
parlons a été un événement fort
messieurs est en fait le premier est
celui ci dit venus 30 ans après avec
beaucoup plus de forces et mes 30 ans
alors vous êtes pour l'europe et vos
amis de l'époque vous disent pas
finalement écouté pour l'europe est
situé socialiste vient à ces fioles et
sefyu à l'époque c'est parti c'est parti
de guy mollet le parti de la guerre
d'indochine le parti de la guerre
d'algérie le parti des scandales du vin
des malgré tout vous y allez oui parce
que j'aime pas les petits trucs et
d'impuissance
ouais et qu en plus j'avais dix noms
l'idée qu'on pouvait chante contribuer à
changer les choses
d'autant que
l'invitation est allé me venaient de
copains qui pensaient comme moi il
fallait aller bousculer ce truc et que
c'était la tâche que les jeunes on va
faire alors après les lions - changer
les moeurs noël métier qu'est ce qu'il a
dit tyler était fabuleux à qui vous avez
envie de donner du sens aux collègues
dans la navigation ouais bon bien sûr
mais j'avais envie de donner son
collègue en politique bien fait pareil
et après les faits le même score
alors après après vous fondez leroy pas
faire toute l'histoire enfin vous
retrouver à la tête du ps su qui était
je sais pas où il fonde un moment c'est
compliqué j'imagine mais je deviens le
patron huit ans voilà on est patron du
ps sulky le parti organisé qui est au
coeur des événements de 68 vous êtes un
des principaux organisateurs des défilés
de 68 et à cause de vous vous en
féliciter jamais eu de débordements il
n'y a jamais eu de l'assemblée nationale
n'a jamais été attaqué la bourse n'a
jamais été attaqué les bâtiments publics
ont jamais été attaqué donc vous êtes
celui qui a fait j'aurais moi tout seul
est celui qui a fait échouer 68
finalement pas être méchant mais là vous
venez de dire des conneries
ah bon jamais personne mai 68 n'a eu
cette idée mais il y avait des
provocateurs dans tous les compartiments
et est donc premièrement tous nos
services de nounous service d'ordre les
gars qui vérifiaient un peu quelque
chose se passe bien et est toujours en
queue de manif pour empêcher les
anarchistes les casseurs les voyous
guette d'aller casser des vitrines et
des est de changer l'image de ce
mouvement qui voulait parler au peuple
en se faisant voir mais pas plus mais
c'est vrai que je n'ai jamais eu de
difficulté à obtenir de cohn-bendit de
sauvage au delà gspr de tous les
les dirigeants de mai 68 dont je tais le
plus gros de marc goua enfin tous ces
gens là jamais j'ai eu difficulté
obtenir que gay pas d'actes de violence
mai 68 est un acte de témoignages et
votre violence
en plus c'était plutôt ludique c'était
une demande du droit à la parole
c'était un combat contre les hiérarchies
qui permet pas qu'on cause en dessous
dans quelques disciplines que ce soit
alors il ya eu à la fin de 68 le stade
charléty mme tout le monde était réuni
c'était le le point d'orgue des
événements vous parlez pas vous à
charléty des mendès france qui est avec
vous ne parle pas non pour moi ma ds a
refusé oui pourquoi il sentait pas la
chose il avait passé son temps à nous
dire le gaullisme est dit dans la rue il
mourra dans la rue nous lui avions dit
on lui avait dit vous nous fatiguez le
gaullisme il est réélu d'étape en étape
il ya des référendum la constitution est
légitime ils gagnent les élections
électorales et puis ça continuera et
nous sommes en réplique présidentiel ou
parlementaire
et puis pendant mes soixante eh bien
vous avez raison ouais bon c'est vous
qui avez raison le gaullisme et des
rails peut-être y mourir mais alors à
vous de jouer
elie non je sens pas le mouvement c'est
un peu excessif c'est un peu excessif
n'a pas voulu parler du coup il ya eu
des dents en plus de paroles mais tout
syndicat vous ce jour là le mouvement
était enterré les halls et je crois
qu'ils l'ont enterré le lanceur
surlendemain en fait ça a été enterré
dans les récents cache en fait il a été
enterré le dimanche soir de la veille
comme la défense a défini du parlement
et du coup aucun politique n'a parlé
donc pas moi voilà alors 69 êtes
candidat à la présidentielle vous êtes
le seul leader politique d'ailleurs
d'aujourd'hui enfin avoir commencé par
la présidentielle ouais je suis même le
sol des marginaux en être échappé oui
oui 3 66% c'est ça
fo se raser ce regard des règles à son
phrasé le lendemain matin en teaser
doucette et quand même vous ne
conseillerai fort 66% mais c'était
annonciateur 1
et là vous rentrez dans une opposition à
françois mitterrand qui prend son se
sont non non non
posieux en france au bilan est une chose
bien plus d'un signe que sam des accords
centralité tu sur ce qu'il a fait
pendant le gavage et oui c'est pour ça
que j'allais à safran sont celles que
vous l'avez pas laisser entrer au ps ça
qui était le nom c'est pas moi
moi j'étais militant passalet prenne
cette décision il a tout il a toujours
cru que c'était vous qui aviez refusé de
le faire en servaient sous alimentées un
peu mais il savait tout mitterrand le
bureau exécutif du ps hudon jeu du ps a
way dont je n'étais pas parce que
j'étais un militant de base avait décidé
que on voulait pas de lui qu'il ne
voulait pas de lui moi j'ai lu sarah
presse
en 81 vous voulez être candidat à la
présidence de la république
il ya un gros vent c'est l'appel de
conflans 1
il ya un gros morceau en face fait un
peu un flop faut bien le dire dans la
vie politique et dans les médias
et là vous décidez de vous rallier à
mitterrand pour le choix aux convois
d'investiture j'aurais perdu tout le
monde peut se planter en échange de quoi
vous êtes vous êtes ministre un échange
pour moi comme un bon suivi je vous
démissionner quand mitterrand en
instaurant la proportionnelle pas ce que
vous dites c'est un boulevard pour jean
marie le pen
ouais je te vois mais ça l'arrangé
mitterrand de faire un boulevard le pen
ça lui permettait de couper la droite
ont de jouer mais ça on the police et
que je me fais de l'honneur la tordue
comme ça normal vous n'êtes pas tordu à
ce point là vous vivez de laisser moi
était de même pour casser la droite vous
l'auriez pas se fier d'être tordu pour
tordre et celle une affaire de savoir si
on croit des choses et sion parce que la
dignité ou l'honneur sont des valeurs
avec lesquelles on a quelques
relation êtes être dignité être donneur
pour être présent là que des finalement
le pêcheur vous il doit être possible
pensez support - clémence ou un brillant
il ya des gens de râble me charles de
gaulle tout même les pros nécessaire de
se déshonorer pour être président de la
république vient en 88 vous êtes premier
ministre alors pas très marrant parce
que quand vous dites là mitterrand est
ce que c'est bien de prendre dumas dans
le gouvernement aux affaires étrangères
vous pensez que c'est pas une bonne idée
et c'est parti très fréquentables dumas
et vous du bien sûr pourquoi c'est dans
la constitution c'est lui qui nomme pour
moi moi je propose lui aussi la poubelle
encore un point commun
moi je verrais part alors en novembre 98
a déclaré michel rocard
mon vrai problème c'était que françois
mitterrand n'était pas un honnête homme
et tout est dit lui il en est autant à
votre service dans le livre de favier
martin roland en parlant de vous il dit
j'ai fait l'erreur de le nommer en
parlant de votre nomination à matignon
il dit j'ai fait l'erreur de le nommer
alors on est quitte à matignon il ne
faisait rien c'est gentil serait sympa
il était incapable de prendre une mesure
un tant soit peu impopulaire est alors
par rapport aux européennes ce que vous
avez reprocher mitterrand nous hormis
tapis dans les pattes pour les
européennes ce qui était pas faux lui il
disait il dit que j'ai envoyé un missile
tapis cet idiot une pichenette aurait pu
la battre
en parlant de vous c'est une mobilité
c'est sympa la politique je savais pas
mais je savais que vous aviez dit que ce
n'est pas un honnête homme
je savais mais attention sur ce mot dans
l'attenté je sais ce que vous allez me
dire revenir le moniteur me sens du
xviiie
mais oui mais comme on dit un homme
honnête sinon one malhonnête
ouais je pense qu'on lui tire au sens
que la grande banque française et le
xviiie siècle ont donné au mossad et
hommes il remplissait pas toutes les
conditions que j'ai voulu dire plus il
avait la culture de l'homme est homme
mais le comportement d'un homme parlait
bien alors je pose une question très
sérieuse la françois mitterrand à votre
avis est-ce que c'est un socialiste ou
un vichyste déguisé en socialiste pour
prendre le pouvoir
c'est une question trop brutalement
formulé coup c'est mon genre
oui c'est votre genre mais c'est pour le
bien de chacun sans ce genre de square
être se répondre c'est un homme qui
avait dans le fonctionnement de la
république et les lois laïques de la
république une vraie foi qui considérait
que de voler bas fouet qui a rencontré
la gauche par hasard d'alliance dans ce
combat et qui l'a mené jusqu'au bout
ouais avec ses méthodes à lui qui ne
sont pas toujours les miennes ouais en
parlant d' avouer là vous pensez que
chirac il devrait aller voir le juge
halphen vous c'est compliqué ça
pas tellement il est convoqué par un
juge je suis passé juriste ni assez
informés des trucs pour savoir si le
dieu n'a pas ou un petit peu outrepassé
ses fonctions faucheux à coup sûr c'est
quand même quel que soit l'homme un peu
important que le président de la
république d'un grand pays continuent à
être respecté et par conséquent vous
faire attention à ce qu'on fait foi
tueur de soi un témoin je suis un témoin
c'est pas un accusé
mais tout de même il est gravissime de
d'y aller sans certitude
je ne peux pas répondre mais parce que
je n'en sais pas si en plus
constitutionnellement quand même il
n'est pas faux que le président de la
république ne soit pas en des temps
avant le oui oui bon ça c'est des actes
pour les communes avant qu'il soit
présent de la république alors si
laraque ya toute une interprétation
juridique sur laquelle le juge halphen
aurait mieux fait de se rendre compte
qu'il y avait matière à un débat qu'il
aurait dû faire trancher par ces experts
ou sa hiérarchie avant de prendre le
risque de faire bafouer louis ont quel
que soit l'âge encore une fois la
présidence de la république france est
un grand pays on a un peu de noblesse on
espère on mérite le respect de nos
voisins ou dur on espère on joue pas ça
trop facilement clinton aussi diriger un
grand pays
le problème des bonnes institutions
c'est qu'elle tienne le coup même quand
les hommes sont faibles et ça c'est pas
de la tarte
si proie facile à faire